morgen wissen sie bestimmt ist halloween
der tag an dem die untoten ihr
hässliches haupt erheben und tote wie zb
der berliner flughafen ber ein traum
überleitung morgen ist tatsächlich
eröffnung ist schon irre oder 14 jahre
bauzeit und dann wirst du genau dann
fertig wenn wegen corona praktisch
keiner mehr fliegt das kommt davon wenn
man auf einem alten indianer friedhof
baut was für eine unglaubliche
pechsträhne war das bitte gut jetzt wird
ja alles gut
es gibt eine neue post um den berliner
hauptstadtflughafen denn insolvent noch
vor der eröffnung bekommt der br also
nicht sofort eine millionen
unterstützung dann ist er pleite dann
ist er pleite
jawohl wir fröhlich ja das sagt in
diesem sinne herzlichen glückwunsch zur
eröffnung und zur insolvenz toll wenn
man das zusammen feiern kann
nein wird garantiert durch eine weitere
staatliche geldspritze verhindert wie
immer natürlich für mich ist ja weiß
nicht wie es irgend geht für mich ist er
der eigentliche br skandal dass niemand
jemals verantwortung übernommen hat für
diese naturkatastrophe von einem
flughafen nicht mehr klaus wowereit der
uns immer kurz vor vergeigten
eröffnungstermin wunderbare zitate
geschenkt hat wie man mir überhaupt
keine sorgen weil das ist beschlossen
das ist fertig und dieser spitzen wowi
witz kostet uns alle bis heute über
sechs milliarden euro mehr als das
doppelte vom ursprünglich kalkulierten
gut andererseits wer welcher klauser
regt sich über sowas lange auf wenn er
dafür am ende so ein perfekt
durchdesignten flughafen kriegt er ist
ja im grunde ein airport wie aus dem
manufactum katalog
berlin brandenburg ein exklusiver kraft
airport aus der flughafen manufaktur
wowereit und söhne
wir stehen für entschleunigt des bauen
nach der slow building philosophie denn
nur was lange währt wird endlich flug
die einzigartige vintage nußbaum optik
des tunnels erinnert bewusst am
partykeller der frühen 70er und allein
unsere mundgeblasene brandschutzanlage
brauchte über fünf jahre bis zur
perfektion
wenn sie einen flughafen wollen der
schnell fertig wird bestellen sie doch
einen beim chinesen bei uns in
brandenburg ist der bau das ziel
brl es gibt sie noch die guten dinge ist
ja so manche sachen hat man halt einfach
nur weil sie schön sind nicht weil man
sie noch braucht wegen corona benötigte
br neben der finanzspritze von 300
millionen in diesem jahr direkt wieder
550 millionen fürs nächste ja und sie
wollten doch unbedingt einen neuen
berliner flughafen und da kostet das
halt für immer wir haben ermittelt dass
wir ohne corona in bis 2023 einen
zusätzlichen kapitalbedarf haben von 1,5
milliarden euro
mit gewohnt sind dass 1,8 gut 1,8
milliarden nur für die nächsten drei
jahre
der willy brandt flughafen ist dermaßen
klamm man überlegt schon in umzubenennen
willi völlig abgebrannt flughafen rygge
klar
so ist das halt so ist das wenn man
schimpansen die bauplanung machen lässt
über jahre und dann kommt auch noch
corona zur eröffnung in deutschland sind
ja gerade die passagierzahlen in der
luftfahrt um also in diesem jahr um 70
prozent zurückgegangen
die lufthansa kassiert neun milliarden
euro staatshilfen den corona
trotzdem droht bis zu 30.000 lufthansa
mitarbeitern die kündigung sogar den
piloten in ausbildung hat man gerade
nagelte irgendwas anderes zu machen
einfach wegzugehen ist doch traurig und
auch der offizielle lufthansa flug
simulator wurde schon an die neue
situation angepasst
da steht man eigentlich nur die ganze
zeit auf dem rollfeld in frankfurt und
guckt zu wie die tauben nach und nach
das cockpit fenster zu scheißen mehr
passiert eigentlich ist wirklich ultra
realistisch doch zurück zum br
der wird zwar erst morgen offiziell in
betrieb genommen aber offensichtlich
gibt es heute abend schon eine art
feierstunde wir scheinen also mal live
auf diesen gurken acker in
berlin-schönefeld so bretschneider würde
was passiert da gerade oliver was in
diesen tagen oft vergessen wird die
eröffnung des br ist eben nicht nur ein
grund zum feiern
da bricht unbemerkt ein ganzer
wirtschaftszweig zusammen
hier trifft sich heute die gewerkschaft
der mittelmäßigen comedy autoren um
abschied zu nehmen vom billigen br witz
wir sehen es ja gerade er wird nun
symbolisch zu grabe getragen der hin
gehobelte flughafen gag von dem deutsche
autoren über jahrzehnte gelebt haben
alles vorbei ja sechs milliarden wurden
versenkt aber dafür haben wir bürger ja
auch was zurück bekommen und zwar pures
comedy gold am berliner
hauptstadtflughafen müssen zwei
kilometer wasserrohre der
sprinkleranlage ausgetauscht werden
auch eine defekte entrauchung anlage zu
kurze rolltreppen die gepäckausgabe am
neuen flughafen ber ist schon vor der
inbetriebnahme zu klein zudem klemmte es
bei rund 1000 türen im terminal 600
brandschutzwände sind fehlerhaft falsche
gasbeton steine verwendet wurden bei den
arbeiten am flughafen berlin brandenburg
haben in den vergangenen jahren
fachleute den brandschutz überwacht die
gar keine fachleute waren die bundes
doch noch zu frisch
leute es gibt ja hoffnung es gibt
hoffnung kollegen der br ist natürlich
nicht das letzte großprojekt das
deutschland spektakulär vor die wand
fährt
darin liegt ja die eigentliche komik
dass man aus dem desaster original
nichts gelernt hat nummer drei aktuelle
beispiele unterlegt mit dick und doof
musik das humboldt forum in berlin
gerade um weitere 33 millionen teurer
geworden jetzt bei 677 sanierung des
deutschen museums münchen statt 400
millionen jetzt 745 millionen oder
stuttgart 21 ursprünglich mit 2,6
milliarden kalkuliert jetzt sind wir bei
8,2 milliarden für einen so lustig
finden woran liegt es denn unsere
chronische rechenschwäche ja das läuft
jedes mal gleich pass auf den zuschlag
kriegt immer die baufirma die am
niedrigsten kalkuliert also liegt jedes
mal hinzukommen kaputtgespart völlig
überforderte baubehörden tatsächlich hat
die bundesregierung schon vor jahren
eine kommission beauftragt ihr zu
erklären was man bei großprojekten
besser machen müsste empfehlung der
experten bitte anschnallen mit dem bau
erst nach erstellung eines dokuments zu
beginnen
dass die ausführungsplanung für das
gesamte projekt sowie detaillierte
angaben zu kosten risiken und zum
zeitplan enthält wie jetzt erst plan
dann baue ich weiß klingt total verrückt
deshalb wurde das auch noch nie versucht
mit anderen worten kopf hoch kollegen da
kommen noch viele neue ps auf uns zu ach
weißte was kommt wir können uns noch
einen lustigen ber baustellen clip
sorry schon wieder vergessen
es ist einfach zu emotional natürlich
mein beileid britta schneider
[Musik]
was denn die über meinen arsch
geigensolo war doch versprochen
ihr könnt ja in der zeit den kanal
abonnieren
[Musik]